The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, welcome
back, everybody, to 8.03.
Today we are going to continue
the discussion of wave equation
starting from last lecture.
So what have we
learned last time?
As a reminder, we have started
to study the behavior of a wave
equation.
We understood basic behavior
of the wave equation,
and also are trying to solve
the general solution of the wave
equation.
The first thing
which we learned,
as usual, is the normal modes.
What are the normal
modes in the case
of wave equation over continuous
translations in metric system.
What we found last time is
that they are standing waves.
And of course, as usual,
the full solution,
which is a general
description of this system,
is the superposition of
infinite number of normal modes.
And that means
one can understand
this kind of system
systematically
the using Fourier series.
So this is just a reminder.
So what we have done
is that basically we
start with infinite number
of coupled oscillators.
And we make the space
between those massive objects
in the system
smaller and smaller
until it become
continuous, right?
And a very interesting
thing happened
that automatically already
give you wave equations, OK?
Which is as you're shown here.
Last time, as I mentioned, we
discussed the normal modes,
which are standing waves.
Those are the first
few normal modes,
and those are the functional
form of the normal modes, which
are standing waves.
So the structure
just looks like this.
So you have A m, which
is the amplitude, sin k
m x plus alpha m,
which can be determined
by boundary conditions.
And the sin omega
m t plus beta m,
that means all the
points in the system
are oscillating at the
same frequency, omega m,
and as the same phase,
which is beta m.
And those are based
on the wave equation.
If you plug this solution
back into the equation,
you will find that omega m is
actually not a free parameter.
It's actually proportional
to k m, which is the wave
number of m's normal mode.
And this constant of v p,
we will find out today,
this is actually the
speed of the wave
in the case of traveling wave.
And if you look at the
individual normal modes
and make product of those normal
mode as a function of time,
you can see from here there
are six different normal modes.
And they are like a sinusoidal
shape in terms of amplitude
as a functional
position on the string.
And there you can see
that if you distort
the string more, then you get
a higher oscillation frequency,
as you see from m equal to
1 to m equals to 6 case.
So as I mentioned
today, we will talk
about another interesting
kind of solution, which is
progressing wave solution, OK?
Why is this solution exciting?
Not just because
this actually matches
what we actually already
learned about waves, right?
And this solution
should enable us
to send, for example,
energy from one point
to another point.
This is actually what
I am doing now, right?
I'm sending energy from
my mouth to your ear
so that you can hear what I
have been talking about, right?
About 8.03, right?
So that's really cool.
And we will try to
understand how actually we
can get this solution out of
this strange wave equation, OK?
So what is showing here
is the normal mode.
And we are going to talk about
a second kind of solution,
which is the progressing
wave solution.
And this solution have
this form, psi (x, t)
will be equal to some
kind of function, f.
And this is actually a function
of x minus v p times t.
This is actually a general
form of the progressing wave.
And f function is some kind
of well-behaved function
of your choice.
OK, so the first thing
which I would like to do
is to show that this functional
form is actually the solution
of the wave equation, right?
So fairly straightforward.
We can actually go ahead and
plug them into this equation.
And before that, I will define
tau to be x minus v p times t,
OK?
So in order to
prepare for plugging
in this functional form
to a wave equation,
I would calculate
using chain law.
Partial f partial x will
be equal to partial f,
partial tau.
Partial tau, partial x.
And this will give you
partial f, partial tau times,
in this case, partial tau,
partial x will give you 1, OK?
And that will give
you f prime tau, OK?
Therefore we can go
ahead and calculate
as well partial square
f, partial x squared, OK?
That will give you
f double prime tau.
So this is actually the
first set of equation
I need in order to describe
the right side of the wave
equation.
The other equation which I need
in the preparation for plugging
in the whole thing
into the wave equation
is to calculate
partial f, partial t.
And according to
chain law, partial f,
partial t is equal to partial
f, partial tau, partial tau,
partial t.
In this case, f is actually
a function of x minus v p t,
and tau is defined
as x minus v p t.
Therefore you can actually
immediately conclude
that these would
be equal to minus v
p, partial f, partial tau.
And now it is actually
equal to minus v p f prime.
Similarly, you can
calculate partial square
of f, partial t squared,
and that would give you
a v p squared f prime.
Oh, f double prime because we
did the double differential.
OK, all right.
So from the first equation
and second equation,
which I have on the board,
we can actually plug that
into the wave equation.
And what I'm going to get is
partial square f, partial t
square.
That would be equal to v p
square, partial square f,
partial x square.
So that is actually exactly
the wave equation, which
we showed from the beginning.
So that means this functional
form satisfy the wave equation.
And I didn't even specify
what is actually f function.
f function is some kind
of well-behaved function.
And it can have all kinds
of different shape, which
we will discuss later.
But that is actually
pretty encouraging.
And that means if you
try to distort the string
and if this shape is
actually propagating at--
have the functional
form of x minus--
If you have any function
which you have a functional
form of f of x minus Vpt--
no matter what kind of shape it
is, this shape is going to be--
first of all, this function is
a solution to the wave equation.
Secondly, we will show
you that this shape
is going to be propagating
at the speed of Vp.
And the shape will not change.
It will stay like that forever
according to the wave equation.
There's another
function of form which
can also be the functional
form of the progressing wave.
We usually write it as f
KX plus or minus omega t.
And in this case if omega
is actually Vp times k,
which is actually
already required
from the discussion
of normal modes.
Then this equation-- this
kind of functional form
is also the solution
of wave equation.
And of course you can actually
go ahead and prove that
probably after the lecture.
The proof will be very similar
to what we have done here.
So now, actually
try to understand
what does this function mean?
So I have a function which
is f of x minus Vp times t.
Where x is actually
the position of the--
on the string.
And the t is actually the time,
which I go ahead and check
this function.
And for example, if I
can give you an example--
a function, for
example, I can make it
like a triangular
shape like this.
And this is actually plotted
as a function of Tau.
So f of Tau is
actually giving you
the information of the shape
of the progressing wave.
So let's discuss if I
write f of x minus Vt,
what does that mean?
OK, first of all, I
can take t equal to 0.
What will what happen is
that a lot instants of time,
t equal to 0, x is equal to Tau.
That means at t equal to 0,
the shape of the string--
well, it looks like
this-- like this function.
Now, I would like to know how
this string is going to evolve
as a function of time.
So that's actually
all we care, right?
And that means I'm going to
increase t to a larger value.
So suppose originally,
I have a t equal to 0,
I'm sitting on this point.
I sample the f at this position.
If I increase t--
if I increase t from 0
to a larger value where
I will start to sample, will
I move to a left-hand side,
or a right-hand side?
Anybody can help me.
Because this functional
form is actually x minus Vt.
What will happen
if I increase t?
Tau will increase or decrease?
AUDIENCE: Decrease.
PROFESSOR: Decrease.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Move to the left.
PROFESSOR: Very good.
So decrease, right?
So that means at the fixed x, I
am going to sample this point.
What does that mean?
That means originally, if I
plot everything in terms of x--
originally, it have this shape.
Now, if I increase t,
what is going to happen
is that originally I was
sampling this shape here.
And now I am sampling
the shape here.
That means if t equal to t
prime, which is larger than t,
this shape first of
all is unchanged.
Secondly, it's actually moving.
The shape looks like
as if it's moving
in the horizontal direction.
And the direction
of this movement
is in the positive x direction.
If I'd write my progressing
wave solution in a functional
form of f of x minus Vt--
this should be Vt
here, sorry for that.
Any questions?
So look at what we have done.
First of all, we
have proved that f
of x minus Vpt, this
function of form
is a solution to
the wave equation.
It's a solution.
Secondly, we also
discussed the property
of this functional form.
So that's essentially
describing a shape.
And the whole shape
is going to move
as if it's moving as
a function of time
and to the positive x direction.
So let me ask you
another question.
So what will happen if
I write the solution
in the form of f of x plus Vt?
Anybody can help me
with the direction
of the propagation of the wave.
AUDIENCE: Go to the left.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Go to the left-hand
side of the board.
That means if I have
another expression.
I'm using the same f function
which is defined here.
In this case, if I
write f of x plus Vt,
that means the
shape will be moving
in the negative x direction.
It's symmetric.
Of course you can
also discuss what
will happen if you take
this functional form
and you are going to get
exactly the same conclusion.
So right now I have been
talking about moving shape.
So what is actually
really moving?
Professor Lee, you
just told us before
that every point on the string
can only move up and down.
Now, you are talking
about something
moving in the positive x
and negative x direction.
What does that mean?
So that mean-- take y example.
So if I have a Gaussian
pulse, and I write this thing
in the form of x minus Vt.
At t equal to 0, this
shape looks like this.
In the next moment,
if I increase time
to t equal to 1, what
is going to happen
is that this shape move toward
the positive x direction.
And of course 0's
are the equilibrium
position of this waves--
of the string.
And what is happening is it's
like this-- so basically,
all the points on the string
are really working together
to produce this shifting--
this progress Gaussian wave.
So what is happening is that
if I focus on this point,
this point will go down.
And this point will go
down, go down, go down,
until I touch this point.
So basically, what
is happening is
like this-- all the
points are only moving
up and down horizontally.
But they all move
in a manner such
that if you look at just
the shape of the amplitude--
the amplitude is
a function of x--
it looks as if the
amplitude-- the shape
is actually moving toward
positive x direction.
Moving toward the right-hand
side of the board.
So what is actually moving?
What is moving is actually
all the point like mass
on the string--
they are only
moving up and done.
But they are moving
together so nicely such
that it looks as if the
whole shape is actually
shifting toward the
positive x direction.
Any questions so far?
So I hope that's
straight forward enough.
And I would like to discuss with
you a interesting situation.
So we have learned
that, OK, I can have,
for example, triangular pulse.
And I can have this
triangular pulse moving
in the positive x direction.
And that we will also
find out that the speed
of the propagation is actually
Vp because that's actually
if you increase t and that's
actually the speed of movement
when you sample the
shape and the f of Tau.
So therefore, we can
conclude that the speed
of this triangular
pulse is going to be Vp.
If I have another
triangular pulse starting
from the right-hand
side end of the string,
they have exactly the
same shape, exactly
the same amplitude.
So of course, according to
what we actually wrote there,
they are going to move forever.
And at some point they will
actually meet each other.
And what is going to
happen is that you
will have some pulse,
which is actually
two times of the
shape at some point.
Because of the linearity
of the wave equation.
So that's actually
pretty straight forward.
However, if I consider another
case, which is like this.
So I have two progressing waves.
One is actually going in the
right-hand side direction.
The other one is going to
the left-hand side direction.
They have exactly the same
shape, but they have--
the amplitude is actually
taking the minus sign.
So they actually are exactly--
they have exactly
the same amplitude,
but pointing to a
different direction.
One is actually pointing upward.
The other one is actually
pointing downward.
So at some point these two waves
is going to overlap each other.
When they overlap each other,
what is going to happen?
It's like this-- they are
going to overlap each other.
That means the amplitude will
be cancelling each other.
Then from the experiment you
will see something like this.
So now, this is the question
I would like to ask you.
What will happen next?
The first possibility
is that they cancel.
Completely, they disappear.
The second possibility is
that, OK, they pass each other.
The third possibility
is that, OK,
it depends on the
mood of the string.
Maybe something
interesting is popping out.
Maybe it decide to produce
two circular waves.
Get creative, right?
Creative.
OK, everybody have to vote.
OK?
How many of you think that
you will cancel and disappear.
Anybody?
Nobody?
Really?
So you can see that
here, nothings there.
Right?
Why didn't you think
that will be canceled?
OK, nobody think
that will cancel.
Very good.
Maybe we are all wrong, right?
[LAUGHTER]
Second, they'll pass each other.
How many of you think so?
Very good.
Finally, how many of
you think that will be,
oh, no, it depends on
the mood of the string.
Get creative.
One, two, three-- thank
you for the support.
[LAUGHTER]
There are four people.
OK.
So let's discuss these
three situations carefully.
So the first situation,
if they cancel exactly,
which sounds logical because
if you look at this string
how could this string
remember what happened before?
How could it remember?
Therefore, shouldn't answer
number one be a logical choice?
The catch is, OK, if they cancel
then that means energy is not
conserved.
So somehow the energy I put in--
I work really hard to shake
the string, use my energy.
And it disappear.
Oh my god, disappear.
[LAUGHTER]
Then the energy is sad.
The second one is, OK, I
believe in energy conservation.
So they will pass each other.
But that means the string
have memory because right
now there's nothing there.
What is going on?
OK, since most of you think that
is actually what is happening,
can some of you explain to
me how this string actually
remember what happened before?
Anybody can help me.
AUDIENCE: Maybe
the two light forms
reflect off of each other.
Bounce off of each
other or something.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, they
balance each other,
but how is this different from
a stationary string at rest?
Of course, I mean at some point
it looks identical, right?
But there's something which
is different between this one
and that one.
AUDIENCE: There's
no [INAUDIBLE]..
No [INAUDIBLE] in the string.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Very good point.
This one, which is actually
unperturbed, has zero velocity.
And this one, no.
It actually have a got velocity.
Actually, this string is
already or starting to--
it's already ready to move down.
And this part of the string
is already ready to move up.
So that is actually
how the string can
remember what happened before.
It remembered it
by the velocity.
So what is actually not
plotted here is a trick.
It's actually the velocity.
The velocity is already nonzero
compared to this situation.
And what is going to happen
is that afterward you
will produce two corresponding
triangular pulse,
continue and then
pass each other.
Finally, the third
condition, creative.
That may not happen because
all the memory is still there
in the form of kinetic energy.
So we can actually go ahead and
do a small demonstration here.
So let's focus on the right-hand
side part of this setup.
So this is actually the Bell
Lab machine we had before.
So now, what I'm
going to do is now
I'm going to create a square
pulse-- positive square
pulse from the lab inside.
And the negative pulse
in the right-hand side
and see what is going to happen.
No, not like this.
Stop.
OK.
All right.
Let's do it.
You see?
They pass each other.
And the shape
actually continues.
So let's do that again.
They cancel at some point,
but they do pass each other
and continue.
And there are some
refractions, et cetera,
which we are going
to discuss afterward.
Let's do that again.
You see?
At some point, they cancel.
But the positive pulse
continue traveling
to your left-hand side.
And then the negative pulse
travel to your right-hand side.
Continue, please.
So based on the experiment most
of you actually were correct.
The answer is number two.
And I would like to show
you a few more examples
based on my little simulation.
So first of all, I would like
to show you a triangular pulse.
They pass each other.
And you can see that
they pass each other,
and the shape is actually
changing as a function of time.
And actually, afterward,
they continue,
and they keep the
same shape based
on this computer simulation.
Another interesting
thing to notice
is that if you focus on
the point at x equal to 0,
you will see that at this
point actually never change
amplitude.
Because those two pulse
are really symmetric.
One is positive, the
other one is negative.
As usual, we can actually
change the shape of the pulse.
For example, I can changed
it to circular shape
and see what will happen.
Oh.
[LAUGHTER]
And again, the position at
x equal to 0 is unchanged.
Let's take a look at that again.
It really does
something really funny.
It looks like, voom.
And then you can see
that it is actually
the velocity of the individual
component of the string.
Which it remember though
in the original shape.
So it can see the
velocity by eye looks
different from what you see it
before in the first example.
And finally, as usual,
we have the MIT waves.
[LAUGHTER]
And it does really,
really crazy things.
And the amazing thing
is that the string
have such a good memory.
It really remember
what is going to happen
before they touch each other.
So what is going to happen
to these two MIT waves?
They are going to be
propagating forever.
Cannot stop until the
edge of the universe.
Maybe they dig out of the
universe, but not my problem
anymore.
So we talk about
the energy stored
in the string and et cetera.
So how about we go ahead and
calculate the kinetic energy
and the potential energy.
So the first part is
the kinetic energy.
Only one is actually
half mv square.
So if I consider a small
segment on the string, which
have a width of delta x.
And I can now calculate delta m.
If I assume this string have
a mass per unit length Rho
L, and the string tension t.
If that's actually given to you
when we set up the experiment,
then we can actually calculate
the mass of this small portion
of the string.
Then delta m, the mass, will
be equal to Rho L times dx.
Because Rho L is the
mass per unit length.
Therefore, what is
actually the kinetic energy
is becoming pretty
straight forward.
It's the integration
over the whole string.
Integration over the
whole string is 1/2--
based on this equation--
Rho L, dx, and times v.
But what is actually v here?
v is actually the velocity
of individual point-like mass
on the string.
And we actually already
talked about that.
The velocity of individual
mass is actually only
in the y direction.
And the position
of individual mass
is described by
the function Psi.
Therefore, what is
actually velocity?
Velocity is actually
partial Psi, partial t.
So that is actually giving you
the velocity of individual mass
on the string.
And then if you square that,
that is actually giving you
the total kinetic energy--
is in this functional form.
Let's also discuss what is
actually the potential energy.
The potential energy as you
remember delta W, the work,
is equal to F times delta
S, the displacement.
F is the force, and the
delta S is the displacement.
So originally,
before we actually
perturb and make some
displacement with respect
to equilibrium position--
this string have
originally-- if I
look at this small part of the
string I join in this region.
This looks like this.
This is delta x, and it has
a constant string tension t.
Now, I can actually
introduce some displacement.
And what is going
to happen is, look,
it's going to look like this.
This string is actually
a little bit stretched.
And this is actually
the original delta x.
The width of this
little segment.
And this direction is
actually a small change
in the y direction, which is
actually showing us delta Psi.
And of course, we can
calculate the length.
The length of this
string and that
will give you square root of
delta x square plus delta Psi
square.
We can now go ahead and
calculate the delta W.
So delta W will be equal to F,
which is the force, times delta
S. We know in the force-- the
magnitude of the force is what?
Is the string tension.
So therefore, I put T here.
And delta S, what is delta S?
Is how much I
stretch this string.
So this is actually
the difference
between the resulting length and
the original length, delta x.
So that is actually
giving you the delta S. So
that means I can write it
in this functional form.
dx square plus d
Psi square minus dx.
I can of course take delta x
out of this square root thing,
and basically I get
delta x, square root of 1
plus d Psi dx square minus dx.
Remember what we have
been discussing until now,
we were always discussing
small amplitude--
or small vibration.
Therefore, that means I can use
a small angle approximation.
That means delta Psi is
going to be very, very
small with respect to delta x.
So that means the first turn
will be roughly delta x 1
plus d Psi dx squared
1/2 because you
have a square root of that,
plus higher order turn.
And of course we assume
that delta Psi is actually
much smaller than delta x.
Therefore, we ignore all
those higher order terms.
So if we actually replace
this expression back
into the original
equation, you will
see that the first turn, 1
cancel with this minus dx turn.
This actually cancel that.
They actually cancel.
Therefore, I can calculate dW
will be equal to T times delta
x, times 1/2 d Psi dx square.
Therefore, what will be
the total potential energy.
The total potential
energy will be
in the equation of the work
dW over the whole range from--
of the system.
And basically, you can actually
write it down as 1/2 T Psi.
Partial Psi,
partial x square dx.
All right, so we can actually
understand and calculate
the kinetic energy and
the potential energy.
So before we take a break,
let's take a short example
to check if we understand
what we have learned so far.
So for example, if
I have a function
Psi xt, and that is
actually equal to 1 over 1
plus x minus 3t to the fourth.
It's a crazy function.
If I assume that I can
do a very precise thing,
manipulate this string so
that I produce a wave function
of this functional form.
1 over 1 plus x minus
3t to the fourth.
Can somebody tell me
what is actually going
to be the velocity of the wave?
Can anybody tell me?
The first thing
which you can do is
to express this crazy
function in a functional
form of fx minus Vpt, right?
And the Vp is actually the
speed of the wave, right?
So anybody know what
is actually-- yes?
AUDIENCE: Three.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the three
because the whole function
can be written as f x minus 3t.
Therefore, the
velocity Vp will be 3.
Of course if you
are not sure, you
can actually calculate
Vp square by the ratio
of partial square Psi, partial t
square, and partial square Psi,
partial x square.
And that will give you
of course the Vp square,
according to that wave equation.
All right, so we will take a
five minute break from now.
And during the break I will
try to return the exam to you.
So we will come back at 24--
12:24.
So welcome back, everybody.
So we will continue the
discussion of traveling wave.
So we have the very
interesting discussion
of two waves that are
canceling each other.
And somehow the
string have a way
to remember what happened
before, which is actually
the velocity of each
individual point on the string
as a function of x--
that instance of time.
So let's actually take
a look at this example.
So make use of what we
have learned so far.
As we see here there
is a triangular shape,
which I create in the lab.
And this triangular
shape is actually there
and it's stationary.
It's not moving.
The strings are at rest,
but have a triangular shape,
which I setup there.
So based on what we
have learned so far--
we have learned
normal modes, we have
learned about traveling wave.
I believe before we learned
this class, the first reaction
to you is to do what?
What kind of decomposition.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Fourier
decomposition.
So what you are going
to do is, OK, very good.
I have this shape.
So I do a Fourier
decomposition and I
have infinite number of terms.
And I am going to evolve
infinite number of term
as a function of time and see
what will happen to the system.
So that's actually what
you would do before we
learned traveling wave.
What I would like to say
today is that if I really
prepare this string at rest,
stationary, at t equal to 0--
in contrast to what
I just said before,
brute force measure,
which I used computer
to decompose it and evolve all
the infinite number of terms.
What we could do is
that I can show you
that this situation is a
superposition of two traveling
waves.
Then the question
becomes super simple.
So instead of doing a
brute force calculation
using computer--
decompose it to infinite
number of normal modes--
what I can actually
show you is that, OK,
if I have a g function, which is
equal to f x plus Vpt plus f x
minus Vpt.
So these three function
is superposition of two
traveling waves.
The shape is described
by f function.
And one of them is traveling
to the right-hand side.
The other one is actually
traveling to a left-hand side.
If I assume that the
superposition of these two
traveling wave is g then I can
now calculate the velocity,
partial g, partial t.
And that will give
you Vp f prime minus--
right, because here it's
actually x minus Vp--
so I got minus Vp
out of it, f prime.
The first term, if I do this
partial differentiation,
then basically I get the
positive Vp out of it.
And then the second term
I get minus Vp out of it.
And these two terms
cancel exactly.
What does that mean?
That means all the points--
this g is actually a
function of x and t--
on the point at t equal
to 0 have initial d
velocity equal to 0.
So in other word, if I have
any random kind of shape--
in this case is a
triangular shape--
I can always decompose
this stationary shape
into two traveling wave.
One is actually traveling
in the positive direction.
The other one is traveling
in the negative direction.
So that means what is happening?
This is equal to a superposition
of two traveling waves.
If I assume the height of
this mountain to be h then
I need to have h
over 2 as the height
for the individual
traveling waves.
One is actually traveling
to the right-hand side.
The other one is
actually traveling to he
left-hand side of the board.
So based on this
trick, actually we
can see that I don't need to
do infinite number of terms
anymore.
I don't need to do a
Fourier decomposition
and get really crazy
and take forever
to write the code
on your computer.
And maybe there are
some bug in your code,
which is frustrating.
And what we could do is
to simply decompose it
into two traveling wave.
And I can now predict
what will happened
at time equal to, for example,
5 what is going to happen.
So what is going to happen is
that you have two triangular
shape waves.
Each of them actually traveled
a distance of 5 times Vp.
So that is actually a
very interesting fact.
And of course we
can see from here
if I quickly create
a triangular shape,
and you will see that it really
did become two triangular shape
wave.
So I can do this.
I can do this.
You see?
So originally, I'm creating
some stationary shape.
And I release that.
It does become two
traveling waves
with amplitude half of
the original height--
original displacement.
I can also do it in the opposite
direction, a positive wave.
You see?
It does work.
And of course,
after the class you
can make even more
complicated shape
if I have many more
than two hands.
Maybe I can do that, but
unfortunately I'm human.
You can see that I can
create different slope
in the positive and negative h.
And it does create
two traveling wave.
And that's amazing
because this is actually
looks like just some kind
of mathematical trick.
And it really match with what
we can do experimentally.
So finally, I would like to
talk about the last topic
of the lecture today,
which is to connect
two strings together.
So suppose I have two strings--
the left-hand side string
is actually thinner.
It has mass per unit length
Rho L, and string tension t.
In the right-hand side you can
have a thicker string with mass
per unit length 4 times Rho
L, and the string tension
is as you keep constant t.
Based on what we
have learned before,
the velocity Vp, is equal to
square root of t over Rho L.
So that's actually from
the last few lectures.
So left-hand side
you will have V1,
which is the velocity of the
traveling wave, equal to square
root of t over Rho L.
And the right-hand side you
will have square root of t
over 4 Rho L. And that will
give you one half of V1.
So what does that mean?
This means that if
I have a traveling
wave in the left-hand side,
the speed of the traveling wave
will be 2 times the
speed of the traveling
wave in the right-hand side
based on this calculation.
So what I would like to
do is the following--
so I would like to ask a
question about this system.
What will happen if I introduce
a displacement and a traveling
wave from the left-hand side.
And the question
is, what is going
to happen to this system
as a function of time
once I actually give this
input traveling wave.
And the answer is that
this traveling wave
is going to pass through
the boundary of two systems.
And there may be refraction.
There may be
transmission, et cetera.
And that we are actually
in the good position
to understand this phenomena.
So let's take a look at
this situation carefully.
So now I define here the
position of the boundary
is at x equal to 0.
And I can now go ahead and write
down the conditions, which is--
need to be satisfied in
order to connect these two
systems properly.
Which you actually already
see this several times,
the boundary condition.
So what are the
boundary conditions
which I need in order to
connect the left-hand side
and the right-hand side systems?
So the first
boundary condition is
that the string is continuous.
Therefore, if I
have some kind of y
is actually-- y of
x t is describing
the displacement of all
the time mass on the string
in a horizontal direction.
Then that means y the
left-hand side evaluated
at 0 minus in the slightly
left-hand side of the boundary
will be equal to YR, which
is actually evaluated
at the slightly right-hand
side of the boundary
at x equal to 0.
And the YL is actually the wave
function for the left-hand side
thinner string.
And the YR is actually
the wave function,
which describe the right-hand
side of the string.
So this means that the boundary
condition tells us that
the string cannot break.
It should match carefully
so that these two
systems are connected
to each other properly.
The second condition
is that, OK,
since this boundary actually
have no massive particles left,
I can't actually assume that
this is massless ring there.
Therefore, the slope
of the left-hand side,
partial YL, partial
x, s equal to 0,
will have to be equal to the
slope at the right-hand side.
If the slope doesn't match
between the left-hand side
and right-hand side, that
means since they have constant
tension that means the tension--
the string tension cannot
cancel each other.
Then the massless ring
will be transferred to,
for example Mars, in a second.
Because it has few infinite
amount of acceleration.
And that didn't happen.
When I actually tried
to actually displace
the string or the
Bell Labs system,
I didn't see crazy
things happen.
Therefore, the
tension at this, which
acting on this massless
ring must cancel each other.
So that's the second
boundary condition we have.
So now, I would like to
make some assumption.
So first of all I have an
input pulse, which is actually
coming into this system.
Looks like this.
And I call it fi,
is traveling toward
the positive x direction.
So therefore, I can of
course write it down
as minus k1x plus omega t.
So this is actually the
incident pulse, I call it fi.
And after it pass the boundary--
so I can actually
expect that there
may be some kind of refraction,
which happened at the boundary,
fr, I call it fr.
And this time this fr
is going to be traveling
to the negative x direction.
Therefore, I can
express this function
as fr is a function of
plus k1x plus omega t.
Finally, there can be
also transmission wave.
So you get the
refraction and there
can be some energy,
which somehow
pass through the boundary.
And I call this
transmission wave ft,
which is actually in a form
of minus k2x plus omega t.
And in this case, I assume
that the system is actually
having a k1 in the
left-hand side,
and k2 in right-hand side.
Which is actually
the wave number
and the k1 is actually
equal to omega over V1.
And the k2 is actually
equal to omega over V2.
So that is actually the set up.
And then also the
three traveling
waves, which we actually
demonstrate the situation.
So we can now go ahead and
plug those three traveling
wave solution into the
boundary conditions.
And then we will
be able to solve
their relative amplitudes.
So let's make use of the
first boundary condition.
So YL is now a
superposition of fi and fr.
YR will be just the
transmission wave, ft.
So now, I can plug
this expression back
into the equation number one.
Then basically, what
I get is fi omega t.
Originally, it's actually
minus k1x plus omega t,
but this thing is actually
evaluated at x equal to 0.
The wave function
has to be continuous
between the negative side of
0 and the positive side of 0.
Therefore, if I plug in x equal
to 0, minus k1 turn disappear.
And what is left
over is omega t.
And this is the second turn fr,
I can write down expressively.
You get fr omega t.
And then right-hand side
of the expression is YR,
only have 1 turn, ft And now
you are going to get ft omega t.
So now we can also go ahead
and plug in this equation
to equation number two.
What is going to happen is that
I do a partial differentiation
with respect to x.
And the plug in x equal
to 0 to the expression.
And what I'm going
to get is minus k1
f prime i, as a
function of omega t,
plus k1 fr prime omega t.
And this will be
equal to minus k2.
In the right-hand side you only
have one turn, which is ft.
So you are going to have minus
k2 ft, the function of omega t.
Any questions so far?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes,
thank you very much.
OK, very good.
So we are making progress here.
And what I can do now is
to do a integration over t
for the equation number two.
So if I do a
integration basically,
what I'm going to get is
minus k1 over 2 fi omega t.
I do a integration
over t, plus--
over omega, sorry-- and the
plus K1 over omega fr omega t.
And this is actually equal to
minus K2 over omega ft omega t.
Based on the equation,
which we have before--
K1 over omega is
actually 1 over V1.
So basically, what
we have is actually--
this is actually 1 over V1.
This is actually 1 over V1.
And this is actually 1 over V2.
So in short while
we are going to get
in the second equation will
become minus V2 fi omega t
plus fr omega t.
If I multiply both sides by V1
and V2 then I get the minus V2
here.
And this will be equal to--
there should be a
minus here because I
am taking out minus V2 there.
And this will be equal
to the right-hand side
because I multiply
both side by V1 and V2.
Actually, I get
minus V1 ft omega t.
So what is actually
left over is that now I
have equation number one, and
I have equation number two.
Those are just functions
of fi, fr, and ft. So
that means we can actually
easily solve the equation
and write everything
in terms of fi.
So we can now solve
one and two and write
in terms of fi, which is
actually the incident wave.
That's actually
what we could do.
So if I do that--
if I solved the
equation one and two,
basically I get fr
omega t, will be
equal to V2 minus V1 divided
by V2 plus V1 times fi omega t.
If you trust me, if I
try to solve one and two,
and express fr, and
ft in terms of fi--
then basically the second thing
which I get from this solution
is that ft will be equal to 2V2
divided by V1 plus V2, fi omega
t.
So look at what we have done.
Basically, the first
thing which we did
is to identify what are
the boundary conditions.
Under the condition
one is the string
doesn't break at the boundary.
The slope match between
the two boundary
because you have
constant tension.
Then I assume the solution have
the functional form of three
traveling wave.
The incident traveling
wave, fi, traveling
to the positive direction.
The refraction is
expressed as fr going
to the negative direction.
And finally, ft is going to--
is the transmission wave going
to the positive direction.
Then I plug those equation
in to the boundary condition.
And I solve everything,
fr and ft, in terms of fi
and this is actually what I get.
So that's actually in short
what I have been doing.
So basically, this
expression is actually
equal to R time fi, where R is
actually V2 minus V1, divided
by V1 plus V2.
And in this case this is
equal to transmission,
which I am writing as Tau, times
fi, the initial incident wave.
And this Tau is equal to 2
times V2 divided by V1 plus V2.
So in this example, V2
is equal to 1 over 2 V1.
So I can now plug it
in and see what I get.
Basically, V2 will be
equal to V1 over 2.
Then I can evaluate,
will be the R and Tau.
So the R will be minus 1/3.
It's a negative value.
And the Tau will be
equal to 2 over 3.
So what have we
learned from here?
So if I create a pulse starting
from the one which is actually
have--
which is lighter or
have smaller Rho L--
smaller mass per unit length--
when it passed
through the boundary
there will be a refracted
wave, which the amplitude will
change it's sign.
So what is going to
happen is that you
will get a reflective wave and
the amplitude changes sign.
And then there will
be a transmitted wave,
which is actually going
to the positive direction.
So this is actually a
demonstration we have here.
So left-hand side is the system,
which I was talking about--
the smaller Rho L system.
And right-hand side is
the larger Rho L system.
And now I can do the
experiment and see what happen.
And I connect the two
system with this ring,
so that they are
coupled to each other.
I hope you will work.
All right, so now I can create--
oh, I'm in trouble now.
One second.
Hopefully will--
this is not easy.
OK, now I can create a pulse
from the left-hand side.
Oh, no.
That is the pressure.
So now I can create a pulse
from the left-hand side.
And you can see that there
is a small pulse actually
that pass through the median--
pass through the boundary,
but unfortunately this demo
is not setup already.
Ah, gosh.
OK, so we will see what
we can get from here.
Now, it works.
Very good.
So now I can actually create a
pulse from the left-hand side,
and you can see that it does
pass through this boundary
if I setup the ring.
The ring was falling down
somehow during the lecture.
And this ring is actually
presenting the boundary
and connect these two system.
Based on what we predict
from the equation--
basically you will see that
if I have a positive amplitude
passing through
the boundary there
will be a negative
pulse going backward
and a positive pulse going
through the boundary, which
is the transmission wave.
And let's see what
is going to happen.
You see?
It does have a negative
pulse going backward.
And you do see that there is
a pulse, which is actually
going through this system.
Let's see this again.
You see that there's a
positive amplitude pulse going
through the boundary
and that there's
a refraction through this--
which is actually going backward
in the left-hand side system.
So on the other hand, if
I start a traveling wave
from your left-hand
side, that means
V2 is going to be
larger than V1.
V2 is actually going to
be larger than the V1.
So what are we going to
get is a positive amplitude
refraction and also a positive
value transmission wave.
And let's see what
is going to happen.
You see?
The refraction is
positive this time.
And the transmission wave
have also positive amplitudes.
Let's take a look
at this thing again.
A very nice pulse and you
can see the refraction
because of this mathematics.
Interesting thing is that it
match with experimental result.
And the prediction
was that you are
going to get the positive
amplitude reflective wave,
and it does agree with
the experimental data.
So this is actually
what we have learned.
So we have learned
traveling wave solution.
Energy of a oscillating
string, and also
the potential kinetic energy.
And also we learn how to
actually match two media
and passings-- how this
traveling wave pass
through the median, et cetera.
And next time we will talk
about more systems described
by wave equation.
And also dispersion relation,
what does that mean, et cetera.
Thank you very much,
and see you on Thursday.